on est dans une situation
abracadabrantesque parce que on a une
des économies qui ont été mises à
l'arrêt ou en tout cas qu'on subit une
des normes restrictions et donc on a
connu des récession historique et dans
le même temps d'aller marchés financiers
qui eux n'arrêtent pas de s'envoler
donc évidemment ça va pas durer il ya un
moment de voir un autre il va falloir
que les vrais prix en fête soit donnée
et comme les actifs réels dans la
société sont totalement décorrélé des
masses d'argent colossales qui circulent
dans les marchés financiers
la chute elle va être terrible et là je
pose la question si olivier babeau parce
que il occulte le débat sur l'union
européenne
mais finalement le quantitative easing
que vous critiquez moi je suis d'accord
avec vous mais alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait parce que on n'a pas eu le choix
après la crise grecque pour sauver
l'euro on n'a pas le choix que de faire
le quantitative easing c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on fait là de la création
monétaire ont fait tourner la planche à
billets pour sauver l'euro c'est pour ça
qu'on le fait donc on a inversé en fait
le fait que l'euro est un instrument est
pas une fin en soi
donc on fait quoi on garde l'europe à ce
que pour garder l'euro faut continuer à
faire la planche à billets ce qui va
créer des bulles financières sur les
actifs et l'inflation de l'immobilier ou
est-ce qu'on sort de l'euro voici une
question je voudrais poser parce que en
l'état on est pris dans un cirque là un
cycle infernal dont on n'arrivera pas à
se sortir
et en plus de ça dans l'euro on a une
certaine politique économique qui nous
est imposée par l'union européenne par
la commission et vous le voyez même le
fonds monétaire international est en
train de dire attention attention les
instances européennes
vous n'êtes pas en train de relancer
assez fort vos économies vous allez
subir 50% de plus de séquelles défini
des négatifs de la crise du coc vidé de
la crise économique qui arrivent par
rapport aux autres pays
donc moi je j'alerte jeudi que l'union
européenne
là est véritablement pourrait sortir de
l'histoire est balayé et prendre un
retard considérable
[Musique]